it's what we all go through and i'm not
talking about the big road projects that
you see me talking about on the news
almost every day
looking on the old big squeeze 95 515
just those two lanes as you know the old
nightmare on nellis drivers and one of
the busiest technically of course it's
not true that every single intersection
is a construction zone but just wanted
to acknowledge what we all say every day
sure seems like the whole valley is a
construction zone like if i didn't tell
you that this intersection just happens
to be jones and vegas drive would you be
able to tell
no real big deal here or at most of the
dozens and dozens and dozens of other
grin and barrett intersections just
life in the concrete and asphalt jungle
we call las vegas
now as long as i was in this area
thought i'd show you the rubble left
behind but the fire here just over a
month ago the one that destroyed a meat
market and shut down the mexican
restaurant next door
yeah that two alarm no injury fire was
february 24th completely closed jones at
vegas drive but now it's just another
construction zone buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com